so I spotted something outside if it's
what I think it is I gotta get one
real
[Music]
you ever do something live where you
just look back and think
well that was a waste of [ __ ] money
[Music]
hello if you didn't know I have a
podcast called trash taste and last year
we did a figure challenge where we spent
1 500 buying anime figurines to decorate
our office this year thanks to all your
support we've moved to a new bigger and
better office so we thought why not the
auntie and spend ten thousand dollars
collectively on anime figurines to
decorate so that's what we did if you
watched last year the rules are going to
be the same we're going to go to four
stores in Akihabara lushing Barn a stop
amiami and mandarake with approximately
three thousand dollars to spend we're
gonna have a bunch of challenges to
complete in each store with some also
overarching challenges and this time we
have to spend a minimum of 500 per store
the winner is the one with the most
points and the loser is going to have to
do some sort of forfeit so this is what
happens hello weebs and welcome to the
anime Zone
I mean the yakuba zone
yes I did okay look we're starting off
in the Akiba Zone if I don't win this
first challenge as the anime zone I'm
I'm removing the Zone from my name okay
I'm just gonna be called the anime all
right if you watched last year you'd
recognize trashbox Kern he's coming back
for another year so we're just gonna
withdraw the first two challenges now
get a non-anime figure that's so easy
though in here maybe it's gonna be hard
in here are we counting like jrpg video
games yeah that's not an anime if it has
an anime then okay okay I have
get the most expensive anime figure you
can find
get the JoJo figure and do the exact
same pose oh it's easy enough what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] and my second one is get a
figure that can beat Goku
kill a figure from a game that Connor
has played
are you [ __ ]
me do they sell Apex or League figures
good luck guard close your eyes and
randomly grab a figure oh that's easy
all right I guess without further Ado we
should uh go in the store and complete
our challenges let's go but before we
move on I just wanted to talk about
today's sponsor surfshark VPN come on
guys it's 2021 you should know what a
VPN is by now but in case you don't
virtual private Network keeps you safe
and private by covering up like a mask
everything you do online when your
device connects to the internet all that
information is blurred out and anyone
who tries to sleep on you won't be able
to see what you're doing or where you're
doing it from but that's not all because
you can also virtually travel the world
in just one click yes you can virtually
change your IP address to many countries
from across the world I've personally
found this very useful when I've been
feeling homesick and I've wanted to
watch BBC programs but uh can't access
it unless I have a UK IP address
surfsharkvpn also allows you to stay
safe on public Wi-Fi's and also send and
receive files safely and securely
because now nobody needs to know the
amount of anime loot you're sending to
your mates alright
you know who you are so what are you
waiting for protect yourself online
today by clicking the link in the
description and using promo code gig out
for 83 off yes that's 83 off and four
months for free thank you surf shark VPN
for sponsoring today's episode back to
the video alright so this is the first
store lashing barn and there's just
something about going into an anime
store when it's completely empty I feel
like a kid in a candy store right now so
let's get looking before we go any
further I wanted to introduce my camera
woman for the day hey guys
I don't know what else is
it it sits now go subscribe all right
give me the [ __ ] camera she's gonna
be my partner in crime for the day for
the day or for life
all right so I've got two challenges
I've got to find the most expensive
figure and a figure from a game that
Connor's played now I know Connor plays
Apex I know Connor plays League that's
pretty much it so I have no idea what
else he's played I'm just gonna have to
like take a stab in the dark and even
hope that he's played any of these games
this one's already pretty expensive
we've got some Final Fantasy figures for
110 bucks that's aerith though I'm more
of a Tifa guy really damn boy she thick
I don't know how we've done this but
we've inadvertently just walked into the
hentai corner so this is just hentai
figures can we show that on YouTube
Sydney Sydney Sydney this is not your
channel Sydney no no please Sydney I
want to get monetized please both of
these are 220 which is the most
expensive figure thus far Sydney what do
you think of these figures I am very
curious about this one just because the
tits look so big
holy [ __ ] it's a yawn figure this is a
figure from one of my favorite artists
he did the art for Miri tights this one
I'm definitely buying this is 121 oh
[ __ ] the only thing that can combat lead
figures for price is apparently
fate figures because of course it would
be holy sh this is 340 who is this oh
it's this [ __ ] oh okay holy [ __ ] look
how badass this is
550 for this [ __ ] this isn't the
figure anymore we've gone beyond the
territory of figure we are just at
girthy statue we're gonna see if we can
find a figure more expensive I'm really
hoping we don't just so I can buy this
figure anything more expensive than the
Fate figure I'm honestly just tempted
just to like throw a Hail Mary and just
hope that Connor hasn't found something
more more expensive because I actually
just want to buy the Fate figure oh
that's pretty expensive is that more
expensive than the fake figure I don't
think it is I don't think it is you know
I think I'm just gonna go for the Fate
figure I'm gonna put my face in fate
fans that they're going to get me
through this game we got some re-zero
figures none that are as expensive as
the Fate figure though
oh no
it's a seven hundred dollars figure it's
familiar as well I don't really want
this figured one
I really want this figure so bad oh no
do you want a wind guard or do you want
to have taste I don't know I feel like
[ __ ] Subaru right now immediately
you're just [ __ ] me over we've got
badasses compared to [ __ ] Amelia come
on really are you really gonna make me
choose What's it gonna be
you know I'm
I'm gonna follow my heart my heart says
this [ __ ] a 700 and media statue I've
gotta go with this are you with me on
this Sydney yes I'm with you okay good
that's why I'm marrying you Cola what
have you done Connor what have you done
kind of just like thieving the [ __ ]
store already all right we're gonna
quickly find a game is it bigger that we
need to buy [ __ ] it is a figure [ __ ] I'm
all out of luck we don't have much time
do we Anna okay 15 minutes 15 minutes to
find a figure from a [ __ ] game of
cosplayed Connor why could you not play
more jrpgs Jesus Christ is this monster
hunter has Connor played Monster Hunter
this is love live bang dream an idol
master I shouldn't be here right now
um fate figures Thomas played fate go
right he's he's playing Faygo surely
surely he used to play Arc nights but uh
there are no Arc Knight figures around
I'm like drawing out straws here this is
my last chance does Yu-Gi-Oh count as a
game that's Connor played Yu-Gi-Oh Mega
Man Mega Man [ __ ] what do you played
Mega Man there's a bunch of figures here
anime anime anime love life love life
Sword Art Online that causes a video
game right Connor why have you not
listened to me I've played Persona 5.
I've been recommending this game to you
for about five years now but no you
refuse to play jrpg God I hate you it
basically comes down to I got it we got
it boys we got it we got it Mario thank
you thank you Chris Pratt thank you so
much it's me and Mario or I could just
be simple and buy this Pikachu one I'm
Gonna Save him budget I need every cent
okay here's what I'm thinking do I buy
the Amelia no is it worth losing a point
let's just go buy figures so that came
out to uh
670 I can barely hold the girth of this
thing look at that I think I've actually
found a character figure from a game
you've played oh really oh yeah yeah
well I'll have to see it or is it a
surprise no it's not a surprise so that
was lushing ban
um I don't know if I've made a massive
Mistake by not buying the Amelia figure
but I guess we'll leave it to fate so
we'll see you in the next door I get it
what we'll leave it to fate
so here we are the second store we are
back in the Akiba Zone this time we're
going to a stop which is the same store
we went to last year so once we go in
you're probably going to recognize it
but before we go in let's find out what
our challenges are Sydney how do you
think I'm doing so far well you spent
the most so far but you know I kind of
took an L on one of them no no don't
don't say that don't say that Joey's
right there trash box good round two
here we go all right this this round's
my rounds
Jesus Christ Joey ah Sydney get
something super etchy buy a figure from
a Shonen series I think you got that
last time I did I did get a character
figure from fist to the North Star okay
oh my God this you might actually have a
chance here I do I will have a chance
I've seen them sell it here my second
one is get a figure from a series that
you recently watched
get a female character figure okay the
gacha gods are finally online you can
literally get two points all right let's
go so once again we are in a stop and as
you can see I am surrounded by figure
boxes I got figure boxes to my left
this is my right I got figure boxes to
my left I got Connor right behind me I
think our first mission is to find a
lewd figure now Sydney we've got two
eyes working for us right now that's a
good nipple right there that's some good
nipple I like them I like them a lot do
you think this video is going to be
monetized no so how this store actually
works is that this is actually a
secondhand figure store all these boxes
are owned by someone and they're the
ones who set the price it's basically
just real life eBay so like because I
was so focused on the challenges for the
previous thought I forgot that we have
some overarching challenges as well
which are on screen right now so now
that I have a bit more time to focus on
other challenges apart from just
figuring out if I want to spend 700 on
Amelia I think the one I'm going to try
and find is a figure that's close to uh
69 or for twenty dollars let's see what
we can find [ __ ] sake there's a Gojo
figure there's a Gojo figure right there
who's Gojo are you are you serious oh
that's pretty lewd Cindy can you like
not put a pants can you not put our
panties on the screen Sydney this is 438
which is pretty damn close to 420 and
it's a lewd figure worst girl though she
is but we're here to play a game 69.69
to see if you can find something 69 holy
[ __ ] oh
you know what I kind of want a uh what's
her name again how have I know for
[ __ ] sake Echidna that's it I kid 50
off everything in his box so I can get
Echidna for six dollars sometimes you
just gotta look out for good deals
[Applause]
I don't even care if it's Sword Art
Online I'm getting this point oh but it
says 70 off oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] the one time I don't want a
discount and there's a discount oh
berserk we've got berserk we can do
berserk or we can do goblin Slayer
they're both the same thing right I
swear to God Sydney I I swear to God
that's so close that's so close why is
every sword art online figure 69 or
close to 69 is this chapter 16.5 all
over again
oh
um but it's 20 off are you kidding me no
what do you keep getting I keep getting
69 that's every box that has a figure
that 69 has a 50 or 60 percent oh come
on Japanese people why is no one pricing
their [ __ ] 69 exactly Cindy stop stop is
this black Goku or Goku black don't
shoot he's not black this man
I swear it's a girlfriend come on I've
got it I've got it that's a cheap
Chisholm figure I'm getting that I've
just bought white for you so far I
didn't know that uh rental girlfriend
Figures were already out so I'm really
happy I got one for that jeep initially
I thought look how cool this guts figure
was until look at the color of his face
why is he cream it's seasick guts this
is what happens when you spend 12 years
on a boat man spilling his guts oh my
God Sydney stop you know what I'm gonna
get black Goku my Goku deserves to go on
our wall [ __ ] I just realized that's an
anime original film but it's so
expensive I found another Pro math
figure for much cheaper I'm gonna go for
it I don't think I can get a better
price than that what is that that is
Nightmare fuel is this what happens when
you put the anime finger in the [ __ ] jar
alright so we've got 10 minutes left so
we're just gonna cash out now we've
spent over 500 and I hope that we've
just got three points with one figure
I'll be honest I don't remember what
some of these figures are but I'm going
to keep them on anyway how we buy the
figures and they stop we note down all
the figures on the piece of paper and
then the store clerk will get all the
figures for us and confirm which figures
we're actually buying oh yeah I did put
a chisa roof figure in there of course I
did kudos
[Laughter]
okay and that is it we spent
572.50 that is it for a stop so we will
see you at the third store which I
believe is amiami once again so see you
there finally some representation for my
ethnicity then Hey look it's uh your
favorite store it's the minion store all
right so we are finally in amiami and uh
this time we have to wear these face
guards for this store specifically but
we're gonna be doing three challenges in
amiami all right let's do the first one
go for it get a figure for an anime that
Joey has watched in 2021
good luck with that oh no get something
chosen by the other two
you're from an incestuous series and
Shout I love incest why can't I get that
one get a figure from a show that the
boys have not watched good [ __ ] luck
with that good luck with that this is
doable but I'm gonna be hurting do a
squat for every re-zero figure I see buy
a wall swirl easy get a male character
figure oh thank God thank God I got an
easy one get a character plushie get a
figure of a character that is American
all right let's go all right let's let's
just get a plushie let's get that [ __ ]
out of the way what is this I thought
this was like the body of an ugly
bastard does that not look like a body
of an ugly bastard a girl can dream it's
like a little vagina I found something
that you'll love here let me see let me
see come here come here there's a bunch
of Reserve figures right here and right
here there's a bunch here one two squat
that's not come on come on fully spot
fully squat there we go look at this oh
how many have I done Sydney I don't know
I think over ten one two three four five
six seven eight I've done all that seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve three
foreign
[Music]
my legs hurt so much you see any flushes
you like what kind of plushies do you
like uh not Kingdom Hearts well what
about a Pokemon plushie I know Pokemon's
basically look it's my uh it's my
favorite anime it's almost Alchemist
amazing anime this is my favorite
character leave he's a voice by Vic
Manana what about these ones oh my God
no it's like a hamster car cute how'd
you feel about getting a demon slam burn
it
this is adorable as [ __ ] do I have to
get a character plushie I just got a
little little big man all right let's
let's try to find some actual anime
flashes
um
this is this is
perfect why is the hair on among a shelf
who needs this much among her [ __ ] sexy
barkers which one looks my sauce red all
right let's get the Saucy Baka put this
on my pile don't show the rest of the
boys all right and there he goes awful
oh for [ __ ] sake
at least you can't accuse me of skipping
leg day now oh I like this figure let's
not put that one in frames Cindy oh look
at her butthole should I get something
Gundam I know Ellen once we get
something on them I have to build all of
these these are all model kits why can't
mecca just like have like a figure that
I can display
what is this OG Mecca fans where are you
at I would prefer if there was a Mecca
that I actually knew this looks like a
really cool [ __ ] Ava figure I think I
might just want this for myself like how
big is this [ __ ] massive that's how
big look at this chunky boy look at that
hey God hey I'm going to scratch your
back what's an incest anime
because uh I'm just gonna be blunt I
don't watch that [ __ ] Joey just find a
kiss access you know yeah yeah I'll be
all over that [ __ ] if I found it you've
got to think outside the box okay it's
not about vegan it's about the anime
with incest in it I'm not going to solve
the issue for you but I'll give you some
wise words incest is in the heart it's
what was shown out on the sleeve
sometimes you've got to look within to
find the incest just find a little
sister and see where that goes
oh it's heiress I didn't know they made
Michelle Conte figures now no they made
it I got uh by the way okay you seen
this off can you do a little spot real
quick
oh
nipples Cindy what the [ __ ] why are you
here again I don't I don't know what
figures to buy honestly let's get a
hentai figure Cindy you always want a
hentai figure hey this is just like
hello I'm a Discord mod and I watch
anime at this one I'm just shopping
basically completed my challenges I am
happy though because I haven't found a
figure that's more expensive than the
Fate figure I've bought yet what's the
coolest figure here I don't know there
was quite a few cool ones in the hentai
aisle stop what's going on baby oh I
want to get the iris so unless I can
find Roxy for now I just want to be sure
to translate figure oh for [ __ ] sake
all I did was turn around my legs are
jelly right now my legs are actual jelly
oh man they got WarGreymon
I've seen Ava before okay I don't
remember there being a giant enemy
Lobster get in the crab Shinji is this
pre-built metal build damn it if only
Allen was here so we can answer if this
is pre-built or if you have to build
this yourself I'm gonna guess you have
to build it yourself honestly I would
love something mecca for the studio but
I have to build everything these are all
plastic model kits Mecca can you just
give me a figure that I could just put
on my desk without having to build
please I'm begging you no one says I
just needed to get one character plushie
we've got the humongous plushie what can
we add to that how about Steve I think
Stephen Among Us would be a good Duo so
I'm gonna I'm just gonna put that down
there we are back in the hentai corner
I'm not going to leave this place
without buying at least one hentai
figure and you know what I'm gonna let
the queen of degeneracy kick herself so
here's some nice b-roll while Sydney
chooses the figure because I don't want
to show all the figures that she's going
through right now SUNY what are you
thinking do I want that big titty
succubus or do I want that girl eating a
condom keep in mind we need to show the
in the office Sydney I have made my
decision I'm going to choose a figure
that is literally just an ass
God comes up with things in mysterious
ways
what'd you think of this figure it's
just an ass
it's just an ass you're welcome
it's just an ass don't let the boys see
oh shh what I forgot I have to buy
something that they asked me why would I
want that would the ram won't be any
better oh the Ramones be better which
one are you going for you can have
either REM order exactly look at the
mama car no give me enough well actually
it's 300 bucks oh yeah okay yeah I did
that yeah sure you can have that wait
wait how much is this one we are making
an official statement here on camera we
have chosen for gone to buy the MILF
I've got some cool figures I want to buy
you don't have to do it you don't answer
the points you can fall for the point
I'ma [ __ ] do it I'm gonna do it that
was a 300 figure [ __ ] I got 330 I want
to spend left I want to buy another fate
figure a key to alter hell yeah so
you're not gonna spend anything in
mandarake sometimes you roll for a
character and you don't get them so what
do you do you buy them IRL okay all
right well I think we've got a pretty
good haul here so let's go cash out I
kind of forgotten how much I bought it I
think I've spent about a thousand I've
bought a lot I've bought a lot of
figures what the [ __ ] okay we're at 1020
did I buy anything else no no okay yeah
yeah and that is it boys I'm not quite
sure how much I have left for last place
I don't think I have over a thousand see
you at the fourth store and we are at
the final place which is mandaraki I
don't know why I pointed at this like
there was like a logo here anyway if you
don't know what mandaraki is it's a
really really big second-hand store that
has anime stuff a lot of Collectibles so
you can find some really really rare
collectible hair that you can't find
anywhere else I'm excited to see if we
can find some really cool stuff but I'm
also scared because I'm not sure how
much of a budget I have left and out of
all the stores it feels like this is the
one store that won't have a cap on like
the most expensive item you can find
really rare items here for like upwards
of like ten thousand dollars maybe even
higher all right last challenge of the
day get a figure of a fake character
that Garth does not own on fgo yes get a
figure from a show that all the boys
have watched that means I've got the
same challenge that I did last time I
think which was ask the store staff to
recommend a figure for me and buy it in
Japanese right Joey let's go all right
so I think this is a bit unfair because
uh Jerry's got Nabi as the cameraman who
is a fate expert I'm gonna call [ __ ]
we're not checking your account we're
making a well-educated guess as to what
you mean this is meant to be on your own
fate knowledge what if it was an actual
tactic that I invited Navi as my camera
have you not been listening to all the
times I've talked about fate if you did
then no it should be it should be an
easy question I haven't got because I
don't give a [ __ ] this boy cheating
again my God so this is mandaraki and as
you can see there is a totally different
vibe when it comes to the pricing okay
as soon as we walked in there's one
figure that is already our entire budget
that is a 3080 Ava figure just to give
you an idea of the pricing that we're
working with we could have some really
really expensive stuff but we could have
some really cheap stuff so let's grab a
look from my first impression we have
got a lot of like old school [ __ ] we've
got Transformers we've got old school
Mecca oh we've got uh yeah zoids well
this is the last time since I saw zoids
Jesus Christ so this is actually the
eighth floor that we're on right now
mandaraki is eight floors most of the
character figures are on floor seven and
eight so that's what we're going to be
focusing on today but I want to go into
the other floors to see if that we can
find some like interesting things like
what is that I am a hero Curry plate
that's such a unique item are these real
katanas should I buy a [ __ ] Katana
costume we have a lot more lewd figures
all right let's start on the floor below
we're going really old school now this
is marzingazi I don't know OG Mecca fans
where are you at
my OG Mac knowledge is just non-existent
thank God I didn't get the must by the
most expensive figure because I'd be
absolutely [ __ ] this is six thousand
dollars that is more than double our
budget right now what is that is that
marzingazi we got the Super Sentai
corner it's like OG Kaiju stuff because
we've got miles yeah we've got Ultraman
we've got trading cards as well we got
fake Go Cards no [ __ ] way this is
GATRA in real life we've reached the
Pokemon Corner we've actually got
Charizard and Blastoise that's like 700
for a Charizard I'm sure someone who
knows a lot more than Pokemon cards than
me will tell you if this is a good deal
okay so I've gone on to one of the other
floors uh just to have a look around
this is like marzingaziro testogen 28 go
can truly be considered mazinga zero I
think so my God Mecca fans are gonna
like crucify me now I swear to God what
is the Astro Boy what is that so I
spotted something outside if it's what I
think it is I gotta get one yes
so they just straight up so [ __ ] bang
bang bang what the hell look at that
look at that oh my God silly I got an
idea trash taste we love to [ __ ] on
America a lot right but what if we
Embrace part of American culture I'm
going to buy a bang bang and I'm going
to present it to the boys that looks
like a [ __ ] American bang bang bang
how much I have left my budget we we got
to buy it should I get that one are you
able to take that one home let's do it
let's do it let's do it we'll go for the
American on this podcast wait wait can
you get demonetized for showing me bang
bang bang but it's Nestle bang bang bang
right this is so [ __ ] big and girthy
they literally have to dismantle the
shop to take it out that's how big this
thing is
bang bang bang this is this is heavy
this is actually heavy holy [ __ ] this is
real metal
um how do I get away with this I think
my biggest worry is that I get arrested
on the way back uh that's that's what I
don't want to happen I just spend the
300 for one reaction that I'm not gonna
be able to show the product so uh let's
hope it's worth it I've have completely
forgotten that I have to do my challenge
so I'm just going to do that now
a character figure
which only makes us feel like this makes
it easy uh anyone anyone you recommends
to one piece yeah sure let's go one
piece Robin then can I uh can I get that
one yeah good choice I I found someone
with good taste thank you very much all
right and that is the last Point done so
let's try to fill up the budget now
I know you want more hentai figures
Sydney okay this is not what we're here
for I want to find like a Gundam figure
or something or a Mecca figure so I just
Googled it and uh we found a Mecca
figure this one's for you Alan because
my editor Allen will not shut up about
Gundam Hathaway okay so I'm buying this
for you Alan now we can stop [ __ ]
talking about it so that mean we have
300 left over yeah can I get a hint I
think of it okay yeah you can get a
hentai figure Sydney oh my God stop you
want the osunagi figure there's so many
I want okay I I like this one a lot
because it's just really aesthetic but
also asanagi so I kind of want Asana
why'd you want the asunagi figure
because it's culture it's beautiful we
can get the awesome algae figure okay
okay we're looking for something for
2010 2050 yeah it's a it's a saber
t-shirt sure why not how much is it oh
no it's 2200 all right I think I've
calculated this correctly they're just
like a plushie I don't [ __ ] know man
this is just a plushie of I don't
recognize this and this is a phone case
order no this is too much [ __ ] I need
something for like exactly 2 000 but
everything is like 2200. was the tax
included I can't remember are you gonna
take the Elder I'm going to take a risk
I hope I haven't gone bust we're going
to go downstairs to pay away from the
rest of the guys and that is it I'm not
gonna reveal my final price right now
you can find that out on the trash taste
podcast where we're gonna basically
figure out who spent closest to
333 dollars so with that said I'll see
you outside with the boys and Gamers
that was it if you want to see their
reactions to what I've bought then head
over to the trash taste podcast right
now if everything goes to plans then the
episode should be released right now so
you can see their reactions also check
out their videos if you want to see
their point of view as well and uh that
was it as I said you can check out all
the different points of view in the
description below and also the podcast
unboxing episode and once again thank
you to lashing Barn a stop amiami and on
the rocky for letting us film there I
had a lot of fun this year so links in
the description if you want to check out
any of their stores hope you guys check
out the podcast because at the moment of
recording I literally don't know who's
won or lost yet anyway though that's it
for me today I've been gig up and I'll
see you all next time